Hey guys.
So, this video will admittedly be something
completely different today.
Because I wanna introduce to you guys a new
series that I’ve discovered this week and
also discuss its latest chapter a little.
The series I’m talking about is Kaiju number
8.
I stumbled across it when looking for a new
series to start on Mangaplus and it’s actually
listed as the 8th most popular series there
at the moment, even before the likes of chainsaw
man or Jiujutsu Kaisen.
And since there are only 9 chapters so far
and the cover art looked pretty damn awesome,
I figured I’d give it a go.
And holy shit, what a story it is.
if you want to start reading before watching
this video, all 9 chapters are free to read
so far.
The link is in the description below, just
make sure to come back afterwards.
There are a number of familiar concepts in
here that we already know from other manga,
but so far that really doesn’t seem to be
a bad thing at all.
Just the opposite.
The series, written and illustrated by Naoya
Matsumoto takes place in modern-day Tokyo.
The only difference is that for some still
unknown reason enormous monsters pop up to
harass the people at times, threatening civilisation.
To counter this, the country has created the
so called defence force, which’s sole purpose
is to destroy these enormous creatures.
Their strongest member is Mina Ashiro a tough-looking
woman that we see destroy one of these gigantuous
beasts with relative ease.
Up top this point the story carries some aspects
of both attack on titan as well as pacific
rim.
However Kaiju no 8 addresses an issue that
most giant monster stories gloss over: What
happens once these beasts have been killed?
This is where the main character of the story
comes into play.
The 32 year old Kafka, who’s name is drawn
from the 20th century author Franz Kafka,
dreamed of joining the defence force, but
has failed to pass the entrance exam multiple
times and has given up on his dream.
Kafka was childhood friends with Mina.
The two made a vow to join the Defense Force
and protect Japan from the Kaiju together
after seeing their town destroyed.
After failing to follow Mina however, he has
joined the so-called Kaiju Cleanup Corp instead.
His job as a Monster Sweeper is to chop up
and dispose of Kaiju killed by the Defense
Force.
And so for a change, we learn about the nasty
side of killing large creatures in a civilian
area and how to lean up the mess they leave.
However, everything changes for Kafka, when
the ambitious 18-year-old Ichikawa is assigned
to work with Kafka.
Ichikawa also has plans to take the exam to
become a member of the Defense Force and with
his strong determination manages to ignite
Kafka’s will once again.
After being attacked by a so-called YoJu,
smaller monsters that accompany the main Kaiju
when they emerge, both Kafka and Ichikawa
stand their ground, but end up in the hospital.
There Kafka is infected by a small parasite-like
monster and suddenly his body transforms into
a small, but powerful monster himself.
When another monster appears in the city,
he defeats it with ease and is from here on
out known as Kaiju number 8, wanted by the
public.
This is of course a reference to Franz Kafka’s
story the Metamorphosis, where the main character
one day wakes up transformed into a giant
insect.
From here on out, Kafka learns to control
his new powers at will and with his new-found
strength he and Ichikawa participate in the
next entrance exam.
Here they meet Kikoru Shinomiya.
Kikoru is the daughter of the Defense Force
Commander and her Combat Power is greater
than any of the other applicants.
Kikoru is viewed as the hope for Japan and
the future leader of the Defense Force, but
suffers heavily under her fathers high expectations.
During the exam, she easily disposes of the
smaller monsters that have been set as obstacles,
similar to the entrance exam in my hero academia.
Kikoru defeats most of them, including the
main monster in a short amount of time.
However, suddenly a mysterious humanoid Kaiju,
similar to Kafka’s transformation appears,
who revives the monster and gives it a power-up.
Quickly it defeats Kikoru and threatens to
kill her.
In the last moment, Kafka decides to reveal
his power in front of her and takes out the
monster with ease.
In the latest chapter, we see the aftermath
of the fight and learn that he mysterious
monster has infiltrated the Monster Sweeper
force by taking up human appearance.
Now, obviously should I decide to keep going
with this series, I will make the chapter
reviews much more thoroughly.
However, since this is the very first video
on this, and most of you probably have just
heard about this story for the very first
time, I’d prefer to share with you, why
I have such high hopes for this manga.
Despite sharing elements with other popular
manga, I believe that up to this point all
of them have been presented in a quite unique
and interesting way.
The fact that so little is explained about
the world and how these creatures came to
be in the first place, hint at something larger
being at work here and it feels like this
story might have quite a bunch of things to
be revealed and explored over time, promising
some great world building, no pun intended.
In this sense it gives me great Attack on
Titan vibes as well, but in a more than positive
way.
The art style also is really nice, reminding
me at times of both Boku no Hero and Fire
Force.
Most importantly for me however, the characters
all seem to be more than promising, as in
the handful of chapters we have so far, there
is already a lot happening in terms of characterisation
and shaping complex personalities.
In addition to the excellent action, good
plotting and pacing, and quality character
work, Matsumoto also delivers some wonderful
comedy.
The buddy team of Kafka and Ichikawa have
created some excellent chemistry between the
different characters in such a short time.
The story also promises to have a great balance
between fun Shounen vibes and some darker
and more mature elements, which I personally
am a big fan off.
Matsumoto also delivers tons of gorgeous artwork.
Many of the panels are flat out wonderful
to look at.
All of them are meticulously drawn and the
action is kinetic and leaps off the page.
Facial expressions, and emotions are also
wonderfully captured.
Combined with great writing and a good balance
between inner and outer dialogue, every chapter
so far has really captured me completely.
And so, overall, Kaiju No. 8 is a brilliant
and fun read that delivers great chapter after
great chapter, getting me excited for the
next one.
While it’s still too early to make such
predictions, I think that the story has enormous
potential and I highly recommend checking
out it out.
You will not be disappointed.
So, once you have checked out the story yourself,
please let me know if this is something you
would like me to cover on a weekly basis.
It really depends on your feedback and preference.
So make sure to share your thoughts with me
in the comments below.
Thanks guys.
Peace.